how to get started
so i got a question for one of my
newsletter readers love you guys
lpr didn't give me the real name lpr
anyway lpr wants to start a new
online business to help people who are
in ontario and quebec do
trail running okay so they're running
through the forest
and he wanted to create a resource an
online place where they can go to
to get all the information needed about
how to do trail running in ontario and
quebec he found that it was
a missing uh thing in the market nobody
was talking about it yet
and so his question to me was should i
do this
right now should i launch it with
whatever i have or should i wait as a
complete resource
and he said he doesn't have time to do
this full time because his wife is going
to freak out on him
what's my advice so lpr this is a very
common problem and i'm really glad you
you wrote and asked about it
first of all it's okay to start
part-time and i encourage it
keep your job do it part-time you'll
keep your wife happy but also you keep
the money coming in because i wouldn't
want you to
quit your job do this for three months
not see results and have to quit and go
back and get a job
the thing is though do something every
day okay something small
even but every day you got to do
something to make this business happen
okay i would definitely launch
as soon as possible something small
something
simple launch as soon as possible
there's a couple reasons for it
one it takes time okay it takes time for
momentum to build
it doesn't just launch a website and
tomorrow you have a million viewers on
it okay it takes
time for it to happen so let that time
build
it's better to launch it small and have
something up there that is still of
value and keep adding to it
than to wait until you have a complete
resource guide
the second thing is you want to get
feedback
from your customer base okay you want to
put something up that's small and then
talk to your friends who are also
interested in trailer running
and get their feedback on it because
then you can
build your website around something that
your customers actually care about
and this is a mistake i made early on in
my career my first software company
the most advanced time consuming feature
in the software
turns out was something that people
don't really care about
only a few people actually cared about
it but most our customers
they didn't care about it now luckily we
had enough other great features in the
software that people would still buy it
but think about how much time we could
have saved and how much of a better
product we could have built
if we took all that energy that went
into creating this one feature that
nobody cared about
and put into something else that's
something that people really did care
about
so i don't want that same thing to
happen to you i want to make sure that
everything you're building is around
customers using your website and saying
wow be really cool if you had this
or this or this so all the features
you're adding in are based on what
people
actually want that will help spread your
momentum and people
feel like they're part of the process
too and say well he added this
just for me this is great they feel
involved and they're more likely to
share it
the last thing i would do is i would
tell your story and put a personal
message up on there
so put your real name on there maybe do
a video if you can get comfortable in
front of the camera
and say why you're launching this
website
what people can hope to expect from it
in the coming months as you
grow it up and that you really want
people's feedback on it
so it gets people to have a personal
connection with you like you are a trail
runner why do you love writing so much
why are you making this
website happen i feel a personal
connection to you
and i also kind of give you a break
because there may not be a lot on there
but i can hear your vision
for what's coming so i know more stuff
is coming i'm going to check in
and i may want to help out and get
involved and give you ideas and give you
suggestions maybe
maybe you need help with pictures or
guides or something else and
seeing that video might inspire me to
want to help you out
so that's what i would do get involved
get momentum
get feedback make the personal video
launch this thing up and when you do
send it to me because i want to check it
out
believe those are watching like the
video thumbs up below
let me know what you think leave a
comment ask a question in the comments
below and i'll make a video response
like this
and you want to see more videos like
this click on my face subscribe to the
channel
thank you so much i'll see you soon
you